[Musique]
la ville de saint germain en tenait à
être aux côtés de ces jeunes qui nous
l'entendons tous depuis plusieurs
semaines expriment des difficultés
rencontrées de toutes sortes et il nous
semblait important à la ligne de saint
germain de pouvoir aussi offrir la
possibilité à nos jeunes de pouvoir
rencontrer en présentiel quelqu'un du
corps médical
[Musique]
on pense beaucoup à peut-être nous à
notre population estudiantine qui peut
se sentir un peu perdus dans un espace
beaucoup plus plus grands et qui aurait
besoin vraiment de de pouvoir échanger
et se et se recadrer le docteur sylvie
en seconde s'est proposé pour assurer
une permanence qui se tiendra tous les
jeudis de 17h à 20h à l'espace vers à
l'espace berra est à cinq minutes à pied
du rer et les jeunes auront pris
rendez-vous par une adresse qui vient
d'être créé et qui écoute jeunes jeunes
au pluriel a de saint-germain-en-laye
pourrait faire et cette adresse mail
sera donc monitorer par notre service
jeunesse et sports et pourra donc donner
des créneaux généralement en une demi
heure pour une consultation avec le
docteur en seconde